de la dactylographie au cinéma du cinéma
à la résistance de la résistance au
journalisme et à la littérature avec
quelques incartades dans la chanson tel
est rapidement tracé la trajectoire de
françoise giroud une trajectoire marquée
par deux traits dominants de son
caractère l'acharnement et le courage
1932 elle a 16 ans elle entre comme
dactylo vendeuse dans une librairie où
elle fait la connaissance du metteur en
scène marc allégret avec lui elle fait
ses débuts dans le monde du cinéma
script girl d'abord puis scénariste
antoine et antoinette par exemple avec
jacques becker enfin assistant metteur
en scène 1939 c'est la guerre très tôt
elle entre dans la résistance sa soeur
et déporté en allemagne
elle sera pour sa part arrêté et enfermé
à fresnes
elle est médaillé de la résistance la
libération la trouve hésitante deux
possibilités s'offrent à elle reprendre
le chemin des studios de cinéma ou faire
du journalisme elle choisit la seconde
voie et fonde avec hélène lazareff
l'hebdomadaire féminin elle
1953 c'est la naissance de l'express
avec jean jacques servan chabert elle va
marquer profondément de sa personnalité
ce nouvel hebdomadaire politique elle y
occupe successivement les fonctions de
directeur de la rédaction de directeur
de la publication et de président de la
société éditrice malgré le peu de temps
que lui laisse le journalisme elle écrit
son dernier livre si je mens date de
1972 une remarquable analyse des hommes
et des événements qui ont marqué sa vie